All right, so here is example number one.
As you can see, the ancient session starts here,
and it ends here, okay?
So you mark out POIs.
So I do not see any POI here, okay?
You don't wanna go way for back and then look for POI.
Just look for POIs near this price action, okay?
So right here, what I can see,
is this autoblock, this candle, okay?
You can see it's a clear autoblock with free value gap, okay?
I could use this as well, this candle here.
So let's use that and consider this week as well.
So now what we're gonna do is we're gonna wait for price
to tap into our autoblock, which happens right here, okay?
Let's go to the one minute timeframe again.
And let's look for market structure shift.
It happens right here.
So now the free value gap is way, way too big.
So in this scenario, I would have used a breaker block,
which is right here, lower low, lower high, lower low.
This is the last bullish candle before the move to the downside.
Remember, so I would take my entry from here,
put my stop right below somewhere around here
to cover the free value gap, BPR, and the body
of the autoblock here.
6.7 stop loss, and we target something like
this free value gap right here.
So you're gonna see price taps into our breaker block,
and we have a push to the upside.
So yeah, that was a clean 3R or 2R.
We targeted this free value gap right here,
and yeah, it worked out perfectly.
So let me give you guys another example.